I think it's consistency of like the
relationship like it that's what it was
for me it was like that's so sweet the
consistency of my relationship sounds
like I just settled no but it was just
like it was just going like this and I
was like yeah
[Music]
and welcome to careful boys well we are
currently afraid of everyone all the
time and today we're talking about the
moment that you realized your partner
was the one was there a situation
perhaps they said a phrase a turn of
phrase they they touched you in a weird
way I think we should start with Nick
you know why because I feel like all of
us have a little bit of life experience
so
so I think through life experience
you're like okay no I don't like this I
kind of like the Toyota Camry but
Beamers are kind of cool and you're like
oh you know but I really like the
Lincoln right for you he knew since high
school yeah you're like Hyundai and then
you're like I want the Hyundai the rest
of my life yeah he was like Elantra all
the way yeah
I'm dead no he got in his driving school
car and he's like I don't ever want
another car yeah two steering wheels
student driver stickers two steers never
won another one how did you know and how
did were you like
I don't care that I'm only like 17 the
most dumbest time of my life and make a
bad decisions but I'm gonna stick to it
how'd you know look me marrying Tiff
total mistake
me staying with her for [__] 15 years
total mistake okay so this is gonna be
kind of lame but 15 years you're a high
schooler yeah yeah so when when I when
we started date well we were always
friends and I just always thought um it
was definitely not just one moment it
was just like okay I think we have
similar values we have similar interests
and things that like uh what kind of
values did you have in high school
though
whatever High School values you have in
your head no but what do you have like I
thought she was very loyal at the time I
thought she was like a real sweet sweet
gal you know and I just thought she one
she would laugh at my jokes that was
[__] very important it's a good value
so you may you felt important and funny
yeah probably because my values in high
school was if I got down is she gonna
jump in yeah that wasn't my value at it
and then the other one is now if I went
to jail is she gonna stay loyal yeah
I felt okay so you take that don't laugh
you know those are probably yours too
but but you take that mindset and I felt
like I felt like she was that kind of
girl for me like she'd always have my
back I felt like she uh she was a writer
you know hers the way she was with her
family I like that I liked the fact that
she would spend time with her family all
the time and she wasn't a [__] slurp
you know what I mean she wasn't a she
wasn't out here hoeing these streets so
I really like that I went in these
streets talk about my high school values
if we're thinking about the lens of what
I was thinking about that and then that
node it down to one I feel like that's
at least 400 yeah but then you're so
ashamed a lot of people but they if they
like it but if they like me back oh
that's that's when it was like that that
brought me down to one I think you
brought it down to one that's one of one
man yeah you're right one so if you like
me that's a big one dude it's a red flag
yeah if you yeah if you just hold my
hand for five minutes I'm like I think
I'm gonna marry you but honestly like
that was part of the the mindset of of
how we started doing I just thought she
was like I just thought she was a good
person I really felt that you never went
like but what the [__] isn't there other
fish es yeah but that's the other fish
ideas mentality
I I felt like I talked to a lot of
different people and I felt like she
stood out differently yeah I would talk
to like random people here and there and
I'd be like oh
there's something that it was more of a
feeling really especially it was like
you were doing test drives somewhere
else we just we just hit it off did you
ever get the feeling that like if I
don't get her now someone else will and
then I'll never get to somebody wow one
of the homies was trying to holler and I
was like
and that was one of the first time I had
to have a conversation with them and I
was like hey man back off that's mine
you knew I was talking bro like you
better [__] chill dude what are you
saying you really had that conversation
I didn't think I was ever that guy but I
did I did have that conversation dude I
rolled them all the way up here was she
laughing at his jokes huh was she
laughing at his jokes you know what's
funny is like back in the day he was
trying to like like dunk on me all the
time oh he's like in front of her yeah
it was he was like Dave Chappelle and
Nutty Professor yeah yeah yeah yeah he
was like dunking on me and I was like oh
and I remember from that day on I was
like oh okay this is gonna be the thing
it was he so he didn't even really like
her he just wanted to I don't know I
don't know or maybe that was his way of
trying to dominating you in front of her
so then it's like yeah and he was trying
and I and I was thinking I was like okay
we'll see when you when you confronted
him was he like May the best man win
kind of was he kind of did have that
energy really he kind of had an energy
and then you got her and then what
happened what did you rub it in his face
nah we just didn't really like I would
have made out in front of him all the
time
I'd be grabbing that ass in front of him
[Laughter]
just making out with her with your eyes
open looking at him this dude was a
little Casanova like he would he would
holler he had like so many different
girlfriends like he was he was like one
of those guys oh yeah I just remember I
was like nah bro you ain't gonna [__]
but she's like disposable to him like
you just watch the next one I have no
idea like the a lot of them are like
that yeah like he's not trying to plant
yeah long term
he could have they could have gotten
married it could have been them two you
know but um but at the time no never
[__] never [__] that dude they
probably would have had Rottweilers
Rottweilers but yeah I just think at
that time I just that's how I thought I
obviously my vision was this scenario
you know what I mean but I just felt
like it just it was easy to hang out
with her it was easy to crack jokes and
have fun and it was it was easy to have
a relationship with her but that's
that's what got you in a relationship
with her and then you're like prom king
that's just important to know because
that's amazing but when was it like you
know you're like I'm gonna tie this knot
it took [__] 10 years dude wow 10
years
like year nine eight when we really
started have a conversation of well I
just always imagined like yeah like I'm
with you so my intention is to be with
you for as long as we can make it work
right but once you come to that
conclusion like what was the thing that
like tipped it over the edge I think
it's consistency of like the
relationship like it that's what it was
for me it was like nothing really
changed that much to the point where
like um that's so sweet the consistency
of my relationship sounds like I just
settled no but it was just like it was
just going like this and I was like yeah
chill it was a moment but it was it was
like proof over time right it's like
it's like this person has my back uh I
think the word might be reliability or
like yeah yeah that's true like the
trust and the I think I think romantic
stagnation
like still water I felt like I couldn't
it was more of like I just wanted to be
with her all the time like that was it
like that's what it really was like I
did it wanna not hang out with her
anytime I would hang out with other
friends I'd be like man it'd be great if
[__] my wife or my girlfriend and all
your friends are like God damn she's so
annoying you know but it just that's
what it kind of was it was just that uh
I just [__] loved that bra dude I
[__] love that hey
[Laughter]
yeah just comfortable yeah they didn't
have to try no it was just easy dude
that was so romantic those CUNY I love
that [__] I mean I love her we should
go to the answer one with the least
demand experience doing one who has had
a 4 000 person body
counts
that's not an internet rumor at all
because that means she really stood out
yeah first of all she had to I just
settled dude okay fine she was a needle
and a haystack how did she stop it
how did she stop you from your player
ways because weren't you going through
on a rampage to like Sweden turkey
wasn't it like like an Indiana Jones map
and your plane was like going all over
the [__] place
I heard dancers are as promiscuous as
traveling I heard that too
okay [__] no just no
all right that's probably why you get
sick all the time you're [__] all the
time yeah your old STDs are come back
isn't there a term for that
what like when you crack your knuckles
and [__] okay anyway
trying to try to follow the Romantic
channel it's hard isn't it it's [__]
hard we're on the magic carpet here okay
Whole New World all right all right
we're gonna we're gonna shut down
everything you said don't sing it guys
we're almost out of time we're all
married guys we're gonna Zing you dude
okay so uh to be honest I think I
mentioned this before but to be honest
uh when I first started dating Nina we
went on one date and then I went to like
China for like three weeks and I totally
thought it was gonna end is that the
kite date yes it was okay yeah your
first one is that romantic
experience I can never keep up with you
man that's experience wait remind me the
kite day real quick he went to the beach
and bought a kite he's just [__]
romantic you already ruined it for him
after this [__] romantic I think the
difference is women should get with
dancers because they're romantic but if
you want to get with comedians
your whole Life's a joke and if you want
to get with the fighter he just wants
stable yeah I just want you to have my
back home I don't want you to do things
for me yeah so so I wanted like a three
week trip so I was like I don't know if
this is gonna last but I just ended up
talking to her every day still and I was
like oh [__] this like works out but
that was like the beginning of my like
hardcore travel like entire generation
so I was like I was never home for
longer than three weeks at a time for
like for the next like six years today's
video is brought to you by coffee meets
Bagel so if you've been watching this
OTR I know you're curious about
relationships you might be single and
thinking like you know what all these
apps out there people just want to hook
up these days I want something serious
well good thing coffee meets Bagel is a
pretty solid app for that because if you
guys know our buddy TJ he was here on JK
news his fiance now he met on coffee
meets Bagel it's a romantic story and so
right there that you can find somebody
that you can love forever and ever ever
with and they got a bunch of serious
people right there yeah 91 of people
that's on coffee meets Bagel is looking
for a serious relationship which is cool
because that means that people that play
less games people have the same goals in
mind and you ever hear like people go
why are you looking for your wife at the
club you ain't gonna find her that's the
hard part if you go to one of these apps
where everyone is just dating
everything's very casual you're not
going to meet the person of your dream
that you're trying to settle down with
and what's cool is like they also
encourage you if you are just looking
for something casual to go to a
different app so they maintain the user
base is always a majority of people that
are looking for serious relationships so
if you're interested in coffee meets
Bagel click the description below they
also have Instagram you can follow them
coffee meets Bagel TJ's just one of the
many success stories that we actually
know about if it was up to me if I
wasn't in a serious relationship right
now and I was looking to settle down I
would for sure use coffee meets Bagel
myself as well so go out there and find
your future lover and get into a serious
relationship with coffee meets Bagel at
that point or whatever you know what I
mean
so I think what that did to me though is
that like in a weird way also kind of
kept its like stagnant I could never get
too far into or out of the relationship
it was always like maybe we'd get in
like a fight and then I'd leave and the
distance would make the heart grow
fonder and we'd come back and be like
settled you know what I mean or like
maybe things were going really really
great and then I would leave and then it
would be like oh [__] I just miss her
and then how come you didn't want to
keep it open because you're traveling so
much you didn't want to go hey like
let's just I think I was just getting
older I think when I was like younger
like before I started dating her and I
was traveling like from time to time I
wasn't traveling as frequently but I was
still traveling I think that was like
definitely
it's always fun yeah but um but you're
like young too you know what I mean so
like you just have different values you
just want to you know make sure she
don't read on you when you're in jail
yeah now you're thinking those are 16
year old morals but that being said uh I
I feel like I was just you know I was
never really able to like evolve the
relationship because I was only home for
like three weeks at a time so that was
like all the time we get together and
then also for her she was like you know
going into like you know uh like not not
a shoe finished undergraduate and she
was going into like getting her extra
credit to get into like uh you know her
her medical school type stuff and and
whatnot so like she was on a whole
educational like higher educational
phase which was really really focused as
well
um but it wasn't until kovid actually so
kovid was when I had to stop traveling
and then she was like doing homeschool
and stuff like that you know our online
courses and we got stuck in this little
ass artificial Box by ourselves and that
forced us to stay there and you remember
that was like months that we weren't
allowed to like go out and it was like
lockdown and so that I feel like was the
[__] first time we really got tested
if we could like do this thing what made
you guys even want to move in we were
living together from like 2000 we
started dating two hours out of
convenience like maybe we should just
move in with each other she had already
started living with me in like 2000
17 I think and would you know just like
sharing the spot because other than that
she was like basically either at like
her College apartment before when we
started dating to like living back with
her parents or whatnot so I was just
like you could just move it with me you
know and then you know she was just kind
of kicking out my spot and then from
there it was like we were living
together in Arts District and then she
like for real we just had to stay
together and I feel like that was our
first real test you know and then like
when like maybe a month and a half went
by and I like wasn't leaving and I was
like seeing her every day you know when
you wake me you can't escape there was a
part of me I was a little concerned
because I was like I've never done this
with her before yeah but it just got way
better and it just like [__] evolved
into this place I just had never
experienced with her before and then you
didn't want to escape and then from
there I was like you know what she's
just my girl yeah dude I love that bra I
just love that bro you know I want to
lock down this relationship yeah we
should get shirts that says I just love
that bra
that's like the most Boomer [__] ever
[Laughter]
she's sturdy she's she's a good bra
she's a sturdy bra she's stable because
the laundry great and she's reliable she
makes a mean casserole
um and then uh so I just feel like it
was maybe 2019 2020 that part of all
that covid uh time took me to like
really just fall in love into different
levels and not be able to leave uh and
it was it was then that it was during
covert that I proposed to her that's
tight yeah that's tight geez so yeah
love that broad love that love it it's a
good broad good Broad
okay that was very sweet I hope you guys
didn't interrupt him the whole time
what's going on because they [__]
hammered me at the beginning
who are we gonna popcorn Bart he knows
how to tell a good story too yeah I
don't
know Ryan because he's one of the more
recent ones oh yeah we're all married he
is it oh yeah
um mine's super super clear because it
was like at a time I think she actually
caught me at a really bad time uh
because that's when I was like living in
a house that I was having like parties
every other day and like I was too much
a [__]
yeah well I was just hanging I was just
he's like yeah I wasn't trying to like
hang out with any one person ever too
much of [__] and then um and then she
came along and we had been friends for
years we'd even like worked together and
done certain jobs and then um once I
started hanging out with her more uh I
was like still kind of on the fence
about it I was like I don't know if I
want to like put that much time into it
and she knows this and I was just kind
of like do I wanna
keep doing this and then one day I told
her I was like Hey like I thought it was
so [__] being so honest and cool I
was like hey just so you know
I'm kind of hanging out with a lot of
people right now so I don't know if I
want to like stick around
[Music]
booze normally guys don't like I thought
I was doing a cool thing but like let me
let you in on what's going on around
I love that voice just to be like but
just to let you know I'm transparent
it's so yeah yeah yeah I thought it was
like I thought it was so cool for being
transparent yeah but it's such a stupid
thing it turns around with a pipe in his
mouth yeah
this is when you do this chair thing
gotta let you know
they're Shades too a gentleman never
tells how many but you know and then but
then the thing is she's because of your
friends like she's seen she's seen me be
myself my true actual self I know she
never saw me turn it up to be cooler or
be anything else and she's been to those
same parties and everything so she gets
the environment and then when I told her
that she had this Vibe of like
[Laughter]
as if like me telling her had some real
estate she's like why do you need to
tell me that like you you don't it felt
like you don't have me so why are you
saying it as if like you're not doing me
a favor
and I was like her name is smack yeah
and I it literally like I could not stop
thinking about her after that damn now
she's the player player yeah did you
pull your hat over your eyes
[Laughter]
it was just a thing where like and I I
never had somebody like just be that
confident about like dude I have my own
life like I'm not revolving around you
you know what I mean like I'm I may not
be here tomorrow you know it's not just
about where you want to be yeah and I
was just like [__] dude that's dope
and then um it just made me you know
like when you meet a girl that just does
the opposite of so many things you're
used to you just are like so drawn to it
and this was a positive thing because it
it took me out of my own stupidity my
own like ego of like I make all the
decision about my life from blah wall
it's like yeah you do but also like
in when you come face to face with a
person like that it's so 50 50 and like
to even think you're 51-49 is like bro
like chill out a little bit you're silly
yeah yeah so from there it I wasn't I
wasn't so like
it wasn't so much that I was like oh
she's the one but I did know whatever
she is I don't think there's any others
of that so that's where I started to
take her like more seriously and I was
like I need to just be a better [__]
human like this is scum
the next day you're like just let you
know like I've been hanging around less
people now
and then she's like oh my God oh my God
as I'm like in a hammock with a martini
how do you Court her after she basically
just [__] packed the ball out of your
[__] face but that's that's the thing
is I I don't I didn't Court her because
I would have courted her if I thought I
was the [__] but because of that I was
like dude we [__] know each other I
don't need to like glitter this [__] up
I'm like hey like play games or whatever
let's go do things that we [__] like
okay and that's it like you want a
[__] banana custard that's our
[__] day you know what I mean like
I'm not trying to like you know go on
[__] Carnival cruise lines and [__]
it's not that that's like the coolest
thing but it was it was very like it was
the most like it's up there though it
does sound like I've never even done
that before we're all gonna do it
together so watch it we didn't feel like
you have to like put up a friend or be
extra about anything you never felt like
I want to get to know the real smack I
want you to know who the real Ryan is
that's the problem is that well not the
problem but like the cool thing is that
when you're I never dated anybody that
was my friend because she saw you in
your true element ever and I think like
when you reach that I was like we don't
have to be like what's the real you
what's the real me it's like we [__]
know that let's just Wow Let's just sit
in the pocket more that's a friend zone
Love Story yeah yeah it really was like
uh I it's crazy how many years I've
known her and like and then we got
closer in just the most like I guess
genuine way like no fancy [__] just
nothing but like what's your life what's
my life was just [__] parallel that
[__] A little better yeah that's tired
that's a Libras
that's cool all right we're gonna have
to do a part two on this one guys
because we still have three more wait
wait
I love that Brad
oh
I'm looking for one huh
foreign